foreign
it's
um lovely to welcome you all here
tonight and um personally I'm excited
um for the the future to get to know you
and get some to know some of you a bit
better so welcome nice to see you
um so there's no nobody from the uh
public here today
so I'd just like to
um
tell you about the evacuation
announcements we're all used to them but
obviously we have to read them there are
no planned fire drills so if the alarm
activates please leave the building in
an orderly fashion via your nearest fire
exit the fire exits are through the main
doors of the hall
or the store room adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobiles and turn them
to silent toilets and hand washing
facilities are available in the foyer
area
um
so members your voice will only be
captured on the live stream when your
microphone is switched on so please
remember to switch on your microphone
when you're invited to speak and switch
off again when I'm not speaking
um
the voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution and
I will ask for a show of hands for and
then against the recommendations and
we'll also ask for a show of hands for
those wishing to abstain from voting so
number one a gender item apologies for
absences so we've received apologies
from counselor Sharp and councilor
Carter and also councilor sparing
so Council across will be substituted
for councilor sharp and councilor Foster
will be substituting for councilor
Carter and councilor
Huntsville will be substituting for
counselor sparing
so is that clear thank you very much
um item three non-members attending we
there's none here is there no
um
item four so the minutes of the meeting
held on the 21st of March 2023
um I don't know was I the only one there
were you there then so I was there so
um I agree to them so anybody else
wishing to
I'll do it
a good reflection to me lovely thank you
so much for those words thank you
um
so are there any Declarations of
Interest members
no
thank you very much so getting onto item
six local investigations and
determinations
um so Emily Ewell a strategic director
will introduce the report
thank you chairman and good evening
members and uh hello to those of you
that I've not met before
um I've been the council's monitoring
officer since May this year
um I'm pleased to present the report
which I hope is fairly self-explanatory
it's a statistical report detailing the
complaints that have been received from
April to July this year there have been
four complaints in that three-month
reporting period or relating to district
councilors and in each case there was no
breach of the code of conduct found I'm
happy to take any questions on the
report but would just remind members
that I can't go into any details of the
specific complaints in order to protect
the privacy of all those parties to
those complaints thank you Tim
[Music]
just ask a question we have this report
and it's absolutely fine as it is I've
got no issue with report at all
but
whilst I would not wish us to identify
in any way the counselors
it would be perhaps helpful to know
we've had four complaints if they were
different counselors or the same and
also if the person making the complaint
was the same person or different people
is there a way of just giving them an
ABC or a one two three because if it's a
lot of different people then it would
indicate that perhaps there's some
clarity on the training required
if it's not if it's the same person
the same would apply for perhaps for
different reasons I don't know if that's
practical I don't know if it's sensible
so I'd take your guidance on that please
through the chair
happy to answer that that question chair
um I can provide a bit more
um
context uh to the to the data that's
presented to you that could explore
things like Trends whether there are
um multiple complaints about the same
issue and that kind of data because that
would still be in that statistical remit
so it wouldn't necessarily reveal any
details of any particular person what I
can say with regards to this report is
two of the complaints are related and
the other two are entirely separate
foreign
also if it was anything that was penned
in on the last report would it be
possible to have those ones carried
forward so you can see if something's
pending
from say something was pending from may
just just for argument's sake we
wouldn't be on this report but it would
so if
it's just so we can keep and because
you've done well here everything's been
cleared up it's just so if something got
resolved an older one that got resolved
during the time that this report that
would be interesting to know so that's
it I'll just say Well done for for
clearing up all the complaints that were
brought to the table
thank you chairman
um Emily I asked you for some detail by
email without naming any names
um I think it would be interesting
useful to know a little bit more detail
than what's here
um and I asked really if it was your
sole decision as the sole Arbiter in in
these cases to decide whether there was
a breach of the code whilst I trust your
judgment who is scrutinizing your uh
decisions in in these matters thank you
thank you for the the question
councilman I apologize I haven't got
back to you ahead of the meeting
um so it is my responsibility
um whether that's a good or bad thing uh
to make the determination of the
complaints where there is no breach of
the code of conduct or where um there is
local resolution it's within my judgment
as to whether to bring in the
independent person or not if I am going
to find or if I feel that the complaint
may be heading towards a finding of a
breach of the code of conduct then I am
required to consult with the independent
person before making that determination
so that's the check and balance if you
like so you know to make sure that I'm
not finding breaches in a kind of
um unfair way and of course we have the
ability to refer any particularly sticky
cases to this committee or a a
subcommittee of this committee to then
hear that case and make a determination
okay thank you and in the in these
particular cases uh why did the
complainants feel that there there had
been a breach of the code do you think
to the um details of which part of the
code is in the report so that gives you
a detail of where the complainant thinks
the code has been breached and then
gives some detail of the behavior that's
led to that allegation of that breach
um I hope that that answers without
going into any
kind of more specific detail of the
complaints
[Music]
a mile there are specific
breaches of the code here that have been
that have been mentioned and and
obviously the complainants had a
a view that they had been breached
um but clearly in your view they hadn't
so
it's very difficult for us to make any
judgment on this because we can't see
any of the details of each case
without naming names is there any more
detail in each case that you can give us
so I don't think I can give my much more
detail about the nature of the complaint
but perhaps it's useful for me to just
talk about the process that I undertake
when I conduct a review of a code of
conduct complaint so when I received the
complaint I undertake an initial
assessment and the first part of that
assessment is to confirm whether or not
the code has been engaged so is it
something that falls within the remit of
the code of conduct and was the
counselor acting in their capacity as a
counselor at the time the alleged
Behavior occurred because if they were
acting in a private capacity the code of
conduct is not engaged after I've done
that I then have a number of items that
I will look through in terms of that
first filter
and that's to help us kind of rule out
any vexatious complaints or frivolous
complaints or complaints about very
historic items and that's all in the
code of conduct complaints procedure
that Rochford Council has and then at
that stage I'll then make a judgment
decision on whether or not the behavior
that's been alleged has has resulted in
a breach or not
um
depending on the nature of the complaint
I will usually write to the counselor
that's been accused to ask for their
response and then I'll use that to
inform my judgment however there'll be
some occasions so for example if the
code is not engaged I would just make
that determination before consulting or
without consulting the counselor
yeah sorry sorry to hog this a little
bit
[Music]
just have one more question
regarding the training session has the
training recording been cut sure
thank you
um
perhaps I've got a different view in all
this it's my view that I don't want to
know who this person is I don't right I
don't want a form an opinion
unnecessarily similarly I'm a bit
cautious about knowing too much about
this incident because it might identify
that person so that's another issue for
me but I also note that it says in here
that you've got the code that you
represented and then at the other end of
the scale is there's no breach of the
code
so using my old-fashioned hat oh I used
to wear if there's no offense there's no
prosecution so he said no one's business
and with what we've got to be in my
opinion is to be satisfied the how that
decision was made was correct
and then I fall back on the idea
people may disagree with me but we
employ someone with that knowledge and
ability to look into some of these codes
independently of us to see whether or
not there's any issues and and I have to
rely on that person and to things to for
me personally to then say we should be
vetting you uh it doesn't feel right
with me well I am interested in is is
there anywhere in all of this so I don't
want to know anything about it at all
but is there anything in here that would
um suggest that we have any which was
already said any training days for all
of us because we don't want to fall we
don't want to fall into the same issue
so I'd like to know me personally when
all these are come if there were
training needs for all of us they're not
the individual because there's no
breaches if there's no breach I've got
no offense
you can't prosecute someone if there's
nothing there so I'm just saying that I
would just like to know what the outcome
is in terms of what it means to us so I
have confidence in your ability
personally and I'm happy with that
that's what I wanted to say thank you
yes thank you thank you for allowing me
to come back I agree with councilor
Norman I think it's an excellent report
it's really nice to see that there's
been no breaches to the coast I mean we
should applaud ourselves actually as a
council that our members are acting when
they're acting as counselors are acting
correctly and I noticed that the report
um has received the report and can I
move that the report be noted please
if I have a second then yeah
[Music]
yes are those comments noted then
thank you very much
and and can I just ask Emily the
comments that they've been taken and
will be acted upon yes lovely thank you
very much thank you for the the debate
discussion we've had around that it's uh
very useful
[Music]
um
so so we're going on to agenda item
seven
standards committee working group
um and Sonja Worthington is the acting
service manager for Democratic services
will introduce the report
members you have in front of your report
which is inviting the committee to um to
appoint a standards committee working
group for the um for this Municipal year
um in 2017 Council uh decided that a
working group of the committee be set up
um for the purpose of agreeing the
content of the member training program
uh for going forwards
um
the council resolution in December 2017
stated that the working group should
should comprise as a minimum uh the
chairman of the standards committee
three other cross-party members and an
independent person in the advisory
capacity members therefore you're
invited to to appoint uh to the working
group for 23
2023-24 as per that Council resolution
happy to take any questions
it's just a point of accuracy it's 24.25
um but I think that the historic nature
of that working group
when was it decided in 2017 we're now
and I think it would be very helpful if
the chairman so agrees
that we revisit the the makeup of that
working group with a fear we've got a
lot of new members we've got different
experiences on board and different uh
ideas
so I'll leave it up to the chairman to
determine but I think it might be better
if this committee re-examines
the
recommendation that was made and passed
in 2017 and puts a new recommendation to
Council on the 7th of September
thank you
finger working
so in line with that I'd like to propose
from the chair
that we do not appoint to the train in
working group this evening but to make a
recommendation back to full Council on
the 7th of September to appoint a
revised working group as follows a
cross-party working group of four
members of the standards committee
I would also like us as a committee to
agree the names of those members of the
working group
but forward puts them forward to the
full Council and any changes we wish to
propose to the terms of reference for
the working group
um
I'd like the second one oh thank you
thank you any comments yes thank you
yeah thank you chairman
um
yes um our group would like to have a
member of that working uh party if
possible working group
um won't be able to name that person
tonight because of holidays and so on I
really like a position on that group and
come back with a name to put forward
before the full council meeting yeah
that's updated thank you very much
um councilor Christine Mason
no sorry
I was indicating thank you Richard okay
um so does anybody here wish to put
their names forward
oh counselor Linden
any of this
yes cancel alarm
and my understanding was that counselor
sharp uh was oh yeah
interesting councilor sharp on his um
Council for sure you're subbing for him
in the ass asked you to actually put his
name down on the working group
[Laughter]
um
thank you
thank you chairman just could you just
confirm that a space will be held for
our group yes so how many have we got
now
so you've got three cancer Council and
Indian cancer Lawman cancer sharp and
then uh a nomination from the
conservative group and it's perfect yeah
good afternoon question for Sonia if we
have more than four we would have to go
to a vote
yes I think so yeah
so what I'm suggesting is that although
we were talking about it now there are
people who are not members who should be
asked do they want to continue on this
committee
no people are not attending tonight
might want to be on there
yeah
so so the actual committee
um the recommendations are that they're
cross-party and we have cross-party
representation there
and and from the standards committee
is yes Sonia if you would have to tell
members that this would be a
recommendation that would be have to be
approved by full Council in any event on
the 7th of September and um as as with
any working group any members that
aren't on that working group can always
feed through their views to any member
of that working group yes
thank you
any other comments
if I might um as I'm the only
independent here I suppose I really
should put myself forward
there isn't
um at the moment there's we're looking
at the proposals that there doesn't have
to be an independent that's fine having
for sure where it goes yeah okay thank
you anyway thank you so much
okay so that goes through to four counts
on earlier for a degree per week and we
have a vote on it please together
oh yes I was going to do that do I I was
going to do that after but yeah so can
we have an agreement
um is that those who agree with that or
for them in favor so those four names to
be put forward to for Council
because we'll have the other name by
then
[Music]
and you who are against that's you
that's it lovely thank you very much
thank you so
um the other thing
um
that we were I wanted to put forward to
was the proposed terms of reference for
the working group I'm really sorry that
I haven't got
um copies to send to you but I'm sure
that they can be sent to you as soon as
possible
um to determine the member training
program for the municipal year 24 24
2025 and circulate
um the full report with the agenda for
the standards committee to be held
um by the end of this this year 2023
that consideration given to member
feedback
to determine any special requests from
members and incorporate as appropriate
incorporate a mix of remote and
in-person sessions especially to the
subject matter
set appropriate provisional dates so
that the member services can include
these in the
2024-2025 timetable with regard to the
established procedure of one morning
afternoon session and one evening
session wherever possible to take
account of the importance of the
regulatory committee requirements
using LGA Trainers for as far as
practicable and in-house training and
other external trainers as needed taking
into account both demands and staff time
and budget and arrange for offices to
provisionally book external trainers to
ensure availability now but I know
there's quite a lot for you all to
remember and as I said I'll put through
but as it stands and if you heard it at
the moment
um can I ask a vote on that those are in
favor
thank you
actually the terms of reference yes
okay
so that's gone through thank you very
much
um okay
um first of all um before finishing
um that concludes the business tonight
but I'd like to thank you very much for
coming along I also like to thank you
for your questions to Emily and for the
the the debate that was had and also
thank Emily and for her responses so
very clear and understandful and thank
you Sonia so thank you very much
uh the meeting has ended at
in my glasses was it five to eight
seven eight fifty Seven to being precise
don't confuse me Richard